[Music]
hi I'm middle Carm The Economist's
deputy editor and I'm Alec John the
economist science correspondent the new
coronavirus has come to dominate all our
journalism over the past few weeks
astonishingly quickly we have
correspondents around the world who are
reporting on how it touches them our
people based in London have all been
dispersed away from the office and are
now practicing social distancing and
really every area that we report on has
been affected by the corona virus and
we've received many many questions from
you and we're going to try and answer
some of them right now
well you know the the virus has already
triggered a financial crisis something
like 23 trillion dollars has been wiped
off the value of shares since
mid-february other asset markets have
glued up in spite of enormous
unprecedented amounts of money put into
the economy by central governments by
central banks and promised by
governments share prices and asset
markets are still really in trouble so
whether it's an overreaction or not I
think is still too soon to say but
clearly even though we saw the first
signs of this crisis a long time ago
back in January when it finally kind of
hit the rest of the world it took
everybody by shock and people were
really shocked at the consequences for
the economy
[Music]
all industries are affected because this
is a strange kind of shock it's a both a
shock to supply because supply chains
are interrupted and it's a shock to
demand because people are staying at
home so you know just to go through some
industries in let's say the oil price
the old price has fallen to sort of in
mid twenties and the best estimate is
that the typically costs fifty dollars
to produce an average barrel of oil at
the moment so that's an interesting
that's in real trouble obviously we see
Airlines grounded and calling for help
we've seen hotels cinemas restaurants
all in really bad trouble I'd say as a
kind of rule of thumb the industries
that produce things that can't be
consumed in future I for instance if we
don't go out for a meal today you're not
going to go out for extra meals in two
or three months time those are the guys
you've got it really hard there are
other people who produce things that are
solid and that might be bought later on
like cars where you could imagine people
postponing their purchases and perhaps
catching up a little bit later but at
the moment I say it's it's really
unclear how long this goes on for what
governments do whether governments and
people lose patience but it looks pretty
serious
the people I think we will see suffering
most as is so often in these cases is
going to be the developing world
I mean imagine trying to practice social
distancing in a slum in Mumbai imagine
if you're an African country that relies
on commodity exports when you've seen
the price of commodities collapse all
the old prices down in the mid twenties
when tourism has dried up when you're a
Kenyan flower seller who no longer can
sell flowers and vegetables to Europe
all of this is incredibly worrying and
you don't have health systems there that
are able to you know don't have
ventilators don't have intensive care
beds so I think you know we could not
only see the disease spreading in in
cities in developing countries but you
could see their economies being hit
reasonably hard too
[Music]
there's a history of emergencies being
an opportunity for governments getting a
bigger role you know in wars in the
depression and this doesn't have to be
malign you know sometimes as in the
depression in in the u.s. although it's
still a subjective that libertarians get
very steamed up about actually you know
the u.s. introduced a basic safety net
and that was that was a good thing and
we might well see public health care in
the United States improve as people
realize that actually the health of the
person next to them isn't just that
person's interest is everybody's
interest however there is also a risk
that the state grabs power and doesn't
give it up and you know people at the
moment are quite worried about Hungary
for instance where they're about to pass
emergency legislation which would give
the government emergency powers that it
wouldn't let have to give up at all it
hasn't given up emergency powers who
took on during the migrant crisis for
instance and it now needs an 80%
approval in Parliament to get these laws
through there are worries in the Middle
East of governments using this as an
excuse to grab power and in Africa and
certainly there are worries in China
that the surveillance of social media as
a means of trying to track people who
have the disease and to get a kind of
social better social distancing that
those powers won't lightly be given up
[Music]
this is a bit of a difficult question to
answer the US and the UK and a bunch of
other countries had decided to take a
very different strategy to places like
South Korea and China where in the
latter countries there's been lots and
lots of testing repeatedly and they got
a decent idea of how many people might
be infected and as random testing and so
on in the UK they decided not to do that
they were testing people who come in
hospital to come to hospitals and not
testing people outside that partly this
is down to the nature of the testing
itself so the tests available right now
try and detect the genetics of the
genetic remnants of the virus itself so
it detects the virus replicating in
cells they can tell you whether you have
an infection it can't tell you if you've
had an infection in the past and as we
know the vast majority of people who get
this virus won't have any symptoms all
will have mild symptoms they could
confuse for something else and so we
don't have a way of testing for that yet
those blood tests that so will test for
antibodies which will tell you tell you
whether someone's had missed an
infection in the past they're on the way
haven't been approved yet and but
they're going to be the things that are
really really important to actually give
you this solid number of how many people
in the community have this without any
condition any problems whatsoever
in South Korea they've done a lot of
tests and and so really they found that
in most cases in South Korea people
recover and the number people who die
are quite low something like 1% so 1.5%
is there is the mortality rate we're
finally higher mortality rates in other
places simply because we actually aren't
testing that many people and the people
who do test other ones are worried sick
and there's a couple of other things as
well out there that you know the the
death rates are a picture of where the
infection rate was two weeks ago because
it takes a while to die of the disease
so countries that are just very early on
the curve might not have very high death
rates those that have already started
accelerating up the curve as Italy has
their death rates start catching up with
the cake rate rates of new cases and I
guess there's one other thing which is
where a health systems been really
swamped then you don't get the
interventions that you might have in say
Singapore where the health systems very
well-equipped for these kinds of events
and so you've always been able to give
people the best treatment available
[Music]
the answer to a question about whether
we're that when the peak is gonna happen
depends on a few things one how
infectious this disease is in other
words if you're infectious how many
people will you likely give it to it
also depends on the model you are using
and the country and the strategy you're
employing and all of that is changing
all the time it's a bit like trying to
trying to land a drone on a sort of
zigzagging speed boat in the sea
somewhere it's really really hard what
we've seen is that different countries
have got predictions of different times
you might be seeing the peak in China
already we know that the peak in Italy
and in Europe is probably a little bit
ahead of where the US is going to be so
we're talking with sometime around us at
the next few months but being any more
specific than that is difficult because
every week they update the models and I
guess the other the other thing to bear
in mind is you know what if there's a
second wave so you know China's looks as
if it's kind of beyond the peak of the
first wave there are now very few
actually some days have been no new
cases apart from those have been brought
in from outside but there will be cases
brought in from outside for for many
months yet and the question is whether
those take off when you get a second
peak so you know in order to be a
pessimist but Spanish Flu the second
wave was worse than the first it's worth
saying that if you are in lockdown in
various countries which many places are
now once you release the gates there
will be more infections of course from
that as well so the strategy that a
government uses can't be in place
forever
until you'll see wave after wave you've
got to basically wait until some sort of
immunity builds or there's a vaccine to
really stop this thing from getting you
know keep coming back
[Music]
so I think a vaccine is the optimal
solution because it's something you can
get in one shot to somebody or two shots
and then in there they're protected and
it means that if they get the infection
they can't and spread it and that's what
you really need so that is the optimal
long-term solution however there are
some drugs you might be able to use to
reduce the number of days that
somebody's sick and infectious we don't
have any that are approved for current
this particular strain of point of virus
because again the disease is so new but
a clinical trial started just last week
and coordinated by the World Health
Organization and one of the biggest
clinical trials ever coordinated and
they're trying out three or four
different potential already approved
drugs drugs approved for other things so
there was an antiviral drug approved for
Ebola in 2019 we know it can be
tolerated by people so perhaps it can be
used a couple of doctors in China and
France tried this out on patients we've
covered 19 and it seemed to reduce the
number of days that they were sick
another trial is looking at chloroquine
the treatment that people might have
already tried for a malaria again it's
one or two cases in France where it
seems to show some effect I think is
seen but you know again we don't know if
that was just chance and then there's
another third arm to this trial which is
looking at an t retroviral drug which is
used to treat and HIV in combination
with a something called a beta
interferon which reduces inflammation
again one or two cases case studies in
America which show that you know it
might reduce the amount you're
infectious but all of these things might
just make people less infectious and for
a slightly less time but it's not going
to stop them from getting infected or
spreading it and it is worth just adding
that imagine you have one of these drugs
that reduces the time that people spend
in hospital if they get severely
affected by the disease from let's say
two weeks to ten days well that might
not sound like much to that particular
patient but for the Health Service it
frees up beds and equipment
and then therefore means that you can
kind of deal with the very large number
of cases that are likely to come so it's
it is valuable and it's worth doing big
tests to pick up these marginal
improvements because they make they make
the system able to cope a lot better how
long we get back to our daily life is
entirely a function of how government's
intend to deal with this you know if you
try and have a strategy of suppressing
the disease but Li which leaves a large
proportion of the population vulnerable
then it'll take longer one thing you can
do I think is through a system of really
a widespread testing so that you can
identify who's had the disease and who
has resistance to it you can then put in
place rather more finely grained and
discriminating systems and social
distancing that allow life to be a
little bit more normal if you combine
those with sort of past sporting systems
on mobile phones that say you know if
you want to get into a nightclub you
have to show that you know you either
haven't got the disease or you're immune
to the disease there are all sorts of
things like that can that may may make
this sort of less burdensome but at the
moment until you get a vaccine the
choices are pretty pretty stark you know
you either accept large numbers of
deaths or you accept a system where you
snuff it out and then what should come
back and try and hit every cluster and
that might not be you know half as
intrusive as the thing that many which
countries are going through now but
distillers have changed to the way we
live what we might see I think is a sort
of oscillating response which is that
you have lock down and then things go
looser for a bit and then you have to
lock down again so they won't this is
the new normal to some extent
and I don't mean like will ever go back
to complete normal until yes there's a
vaccine this is what vaccines do to
society they make
be able to live and travel without
rethinking about it the only thing I'd
add is that you know people are
amazingly adaptable things that seem
very strange become you know people have
workarounds they become normal people
cope
I think it already has hasn't it yes
look at the way we're doing this
interview I think it already has
accelerated he moved to online learning
video conferencing and so far things do
we seem to be standing up fairly well
you know so I think it's quite um it's
interesting it's a good job this this
pandemic waited for cloud computing to
be invented before before it's struck
because you know the shift we've seen on
to online working and watching Netflix
and all these other things we're never
impossible without that technology um
and I think we would have been in a
different place ten years ago in dealing
this was predicted multiple times before
so I suppose what can we learn and maybe
actually have a strategy in place rather
than building it when you see when it
comes turns up I'm so surprised that
Western governments didn't have
something ready in January or February
because it's their scientists along with
the Chinese and others who have been
predicting this for a long time they
knew and in fact there were stories of
like the Trump administration even the
UK government go through war games of
these sorts of things and maybe
politicians have thought these are war
games that will never happen and they
just exercise but the reasons why they
knew what would happen in those war
games is because because we had these
predictions and so I just hope that they
take most seriously you have a plan
actually in place because this a lot of
this stuff is is preventable to some
extent so as you can see Alec and I are
both working from home like all of our
colleagues at the moment but we're
dedicated to bringing you the best
reporting we can with the best analysis
of this phenomenal story as it changes
from one day to the next and if you want
to keep up with what we're doing all of
our coverage is available if you just
click on the link you can see and thanks
for watching